foreign
how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
you bet what's up Brittany
it's been his truck payment is almost as
much as our mortgage oh boy hold on let
me get the pepcity how much are we
talking about Brittany so it's it's
right over 1400. oh oh boy I'm feeling
fake Jade I'm fainted I went into James
Brown mode wow goodness gracious
yeah
Total Money Makeover we're currently um
about to start Financial Peace
universities she understands why we
don't use credit cards and all that but
when he comes in his truck when it comes
to the truck he says I work hard I
deserve a nice truck but I'm just trying
to figure out there's some magic words I
can say and yeah I got the magic words I
got the magic words you're sleeping on
the couch hey oh
oh watch out no I'm sorry that's
probably not the best marital advice but
I do think Jade at this point we've got
a serious conversation he can't be
taking the baby steps seriously and
justifying a fourteen hundred dollar
truck payment I mean I I just want to
know when people say things like I
deserve I'm like really you deserve to
be in debt I because I feel like I
deserve to be debt free I deserve to
have a future I deserve to not live
paycheck to paycheck I deserve to be
able to have the margin to invest for my
future for my children like people need
to reframe when they say what they
deserve or not um so that could be a
place where you start but in all
good uh calmed down advice Ken and I
kind of went off the the spout there um
you do need to sit down and you do need
to have a conversation and it needs to
be an adult conversation because right
now I mean I'm not saying this in an
insulting way but he's in a selfish mode
and he's kind of in a
uh for right now mode and we need to get
in a more futuristic there's more ahead
of us than just right now there's more
people that are
um feeling the effects of this than him
and so being able to have that
conversation is going to be really
important to you
um and I have found that when you use
language that's kind of like hey I'm I
here's what I'm afraid of I'm afraid XYZ
or here's what I'm so excited for and if
we could just get to this that would
give me so much joy like if you can
really find ways to bring
um your fears into it but also like the
things that would just cause you so much
happiness and joy in life those are big
markers and should be big markers uh for
the people who love you and care about
you they should want to hear about those
things and when you share those things
it should cause them to make a reaction
does that make sense yeah no that makes
sense what's the what's your take-home
pay
um together almost 200. okay good good
200 000 take home yes way to go okay so
you look even at that kind of income I
mean this is a huge chunk of your
monthly budget fourteen hundred dollars
massive
and the truck
oh my gosh and and how long ago did he
get the truck
um about six months ago and and what did
he pay for
um I think it was like 85 or 90. oh my
gosh I'm light-headed again so 80 to 90
000 and and you know what would be very
interesting in this conversation Jade
tell me if I'm wrong here but as I'm
sharing those feelings
of what that does to you and how it
makes you feel you've got to point out
how that it'd be fun to get a an
amortization schedule like you would on
a house but on a car it's hard to get
that but how much that car is devaluing
oh it's going down
Like a Rock that's and so he's paying
1400 a month on something the difference
with your house is that's an asset for
you guys the truck is a liability and
where that deserve statement comes in it
starts to to lose its power when you
start talking about what you could be
doing with the fourteen hundred dollars
here's yeah here's the thing
um
Ken makes a very very good point so you
said you're bringing home two hundred
thousand dollars a year right so what
sixteen thousand almost seventeen
thousand dollars a month yes 1400 where
he's at I'm gonna tell you where he's
going 40 I mean we have almost seventeen
thousand dollars a month 1400 that's
nothing that's what he's thinking it's a
very small piece of that
um by the way your mortgages as well but
what I'm looking at is because you have
so much income there should be zero
reason for debt how easy how easy would
it be and let me point this out too
typically do you have any other cars by
the way or is it just um yeah yep we
have one more what else do you have
uh we have a Ford Explorer and how much
is that worth
um I believe around 40 but that's paid
off okay so typically we wouldn't want
you to have any more than half of your
income yearly
in vehicles because they go down in
value so you're right at that I
personally because of your income I'd be
like look we make money we can pay this
off or we can you do what I'm saying
like there's I think there's a way that
you guys can meet in the middle fourteen
hundred dollars a month that is just a
lot of money to be giving away in
payments when you could be debt free
what other debt do you have
um our house and then I have a student
loan how much is a student loan
um 20 000.
yeah so a hundred thousand dollars in
debt you guys have you live on 200 you
can pay all this off in a year and
everybody's happy
yeah let's do it why not yes awesome
that's what I would do because here's
the thing he does earn a lot of money
you guys do earn a lot of money and he's
probably like I don't need to drive a
jalopy we earn 200 000 a year and you
know then paid off but he's taken out a
loan on a truck yeah almost half of what
they bring home she said 80 to 90. she
said somewhere between 80 to 90 000 he
paid for that truck yeah it's too it's
expensive but it's not more than half of
their I understand but it's still
expensive it's re it's out of whack in
that you've got a loan for half of what
you take home he shouldn't have gotten a
loan he should have paid cash he's got
so much money he should they should have
it would have felt so great to walk on
that lot buy it a couple of years used
so spend 20 000 less and walk home with
a car in cash I'll tell you what 90 000
for a truck that truck needs to power
your entire house you know what I mean
it needs to do the laundry it needs to I
mean yeah yeah put the kids to bed you
know the whole nine yards that's a lot
of it's just crazy when the value on
that is just dropping and dropping and
they're upside down I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't do it but I know I know people
do it I mean we've got people on Tick
Tock bragging about how they have joint
uh car payments of twenty one hundred
dollars they're like I
that's what I got